>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Pam Jackson: So
I'm Pam Jackson.
I'm Director for the
Center for the Book here
at the Library of Congress.
And I'd like to welcome
you to our Books
and Beyond Series
this afternoon.
It is our final one of this
season, so we're thrilled,
very thrilled with the
special conversation we have
for you today to
complete our season
and to thank you
guys for being here.
You know, at the
Library of Congress,
we are America's first
cultural institution.
And with that, we, you know,
we live inside our mission,
you know, and it's to provide
a rich and enduring source
of knowledge, one that's
designed and intended for people
to create, to endeavor
intellectually,
to prosper and thrive.
And it's a very awesome,
awesome opportunity
to live inside that mission.
And at the Center for the
Book, which includes the Poetry
and Literature Center, we
promote books and libraries,
reading and literacy, poetry and
literature, and we do so knowing
that they are very
significant components
of having an informed
and engaged society.
And that is the Center
for the Book's mission.
And in fulfilling that, we
have talks like we have today.
Today's talk is a culmination
of a couple of things
that really matter
to the library.
First and foremost,
it's scholarship.
We care a lot about people
knowing what the collections are
here at the Library of Congress,
and that they can be used,
that they can be researched,
that they can be engaged
with for the purpose of
a variety of reasons,
including scholarship
publishing,
and celebrating books is
part of what the Books
and Beyond series does.
So today's event is
a very special one
with a special author because
it's not just about research
that was conducted here at
the Library of Congress,
which we encourage, and
invite people to do,
but it's also a result of a
Library of Congress employee,
a very special one at that.
So I should mention a couple
things before I introduce her,
one of which is to
give us a moment now
to avoid unnecessary
distractions.
Take another distraction,
check on your devices,
make sure you're on silent,
if you would, please.
And that's also because we
are recording today's event.
And should you participate in
the question and answer period
that does follow
the author's talk,
you'll be recorded
on our webcast.
And so we do invite you to
participate knowing that.
And we encourage you
to visit us at read.gov
where you can find more than
250 author talks of a variety
and diversity of topics and
individuals who have been
with us in this program.
So today's author.
Oh, and the book is for sale.
So here in the back of the
room, make sure that you stop
by that table and
make your purchase.
And there will be an
opportunity for signing after.
Now, so, today's author, you
know, the chief criterion
for the Books and Beyond
series, as I mentioned,
is we really want to feature
books that are related
to the Library of Congress.
Primarily, we focus on those
that are published as a result
of research done conducted here
at the Library of Congress.
But more significantly today,
we have an author and a scholar
who is an employee of
the Library of Congress
who is a long-serving and
dedicated and special employee.
And I just, I've had the
pleasure of knowing you
for a bit and experiencing
your scholarship.
There are two other
major Library
of Congress reference works
that Peggy Wagner has produced,
one of which is the Library
of Congress Civil War desk
reference, and also the Library
of Congress World
War II companion.
She's also the author
of five other books,
including Maxfield Parrish
and the Illustrators
of the Golden Age,
and the Library
of Congress illustrated
timeline of the Civil War.
She, Peggy, excuse me, is
a part of our publishing--
she is a publisher and
editor with us here
at the Library of Congress.
And she's going to talk
to us today about America
and the Great War, a Library of
Congress Illustrated History.
And it's a very,
very marvelous piece.
If you haven't had
a chance to see it
or read it, it is fabulous.
It's both inspiring.
It's candid and kind
of straight talk.
And also very inspiring.
I feel like I was
there at that time
as a result of your writing.
So I honor you and
appreciate you.
And let us all bring honor
and acknowledge Peggy Wagner
as she comes to the stage.
[ Applause ]
>> Margaret Wagner:
Thank you, Pam.
Let's see if I can see
over the microphone.
Can you hear me?
Okay. And thank you
all for coming
to hear me talk a little bit
about America and the Great War,
the book and the era
that it describes.
As anyone who has known me for
or who has been with me for more
than five minutes
over the past five
or six years knows
this era is one
that I find incredibly
intriguing.
And I also feel that it's one
of the most important
eras to understand.
It's important not just
for the understanding
of general world history,
but it's also important
to understand American history.
It's also an era for
which the Library
of Congress collections
are amazingly almost
mind-bogglingly rich.
I am the author of
the book, yes,
but I consider this volume
an epic collaboration,
something that you will find
reflected in the two pages
of acknowledgements at
the back of the book.
You'll find the names there
of many of the Library
of Congress specialists
and curators who served
as my professors and guides,
as in this long enterprise
of creating the book.
Several of you are sitting here
in this room, and
I thank you all.
I would also like to salute the
most talented picture editor
with whom I've worked
on a number of projects.
Pardon me.
I am having a frog in my
throat perpetually these days.
Athena Angelos, who
is sitting right here.
And I would like to salute
especially, before we go to war,
my colleagues in the publishing
office who have helped me
and supported me
through many projects.
Aimee Hess, Peter Devereaux and
Susan Reyburn took time away
from their own projects to
read and comment on the text.
Susan wrote The Battle Boxes
that are a part of the book.
And she also collaborated
with staff around the library
to produce the appendix
at the end of the book
on World War I collections
in the Library of Congress
that I feel is a great
resource for everyone
who consults the book.
I'd also like to thank the
new director of publishing.
Well, not new anymore.
Becky Clark, who has been
very supportive, gracious
and good-humored
throughout this project.
So America and the Great War.
This is a huge topic.
And the book explores both,
explores military history,
political and social history,
and it intertwines them.
It is, if you will, a tapestry
of stories within stories.
This makes it very complicated.
So what I thought I'd do
today was present as many
of the images from the book as I
could possibly cram onto slides.
And there are many of them.
And then just try and sort
of hopscotch through the book
and describe to you some
of the points it makes,
some of the questions
it addresses.
And so we go to war.
If you go to today, to what was
100 years ago, the western front
on which almost all,
but not all,
of American expeditionary
forces served,
you will find many artifacts and
scars from a hundred years ago.
You'll also find many
cemeteries, all large and small,
all perfectly preserved.
In France, you'll
find many memorials
and nine cemeteries devoted to
the commemoration of the brief,
but very important, American
military involvement in the war.
But the United States was
affected and affected,
itself affected the
war from 1914
to well after the armistice.
And this book looks at
that entire experience.
The prologue describes
the United States
in the two years
leading up to the war.
The election of Woodrow Wilson
and the prevalent
belief among European
and American progressives,
including Wilson's Secretary
of State, William J.
Bryan, that the era
of major military conflict
was over, that arbitration
of international disputes was
the wave of the present time
and the wave of the future.
It was the apex of
the progressive era,
and the prologue introduces
the major domestic problems
that the nation will continue
to confront, argue over,
and attempt to ameliorate
through the war,
the years, and well beyond.
One of the major problem areas,
as represented here,
was labor relations.
Another, which many
white progressives,
including President
Wilson, preferred to ignore,
was the country's
troubled race relations.
The portrait at the upper right
is the outspoken civil rights
activist William Monroe
Trotter, the spokesman
who so offended President Wilson
that Wilson effectively
banned him
from the White House in 1914.
Despite the nation's and
Wilson's preferred concentration
on domestic improvements,
Americans could not avoid
foreign relations concerns.
The most immediate impressing
in spring 1914 was the
ongoing revolution in Mexico,
the southern neighbor
in which more
than 40,000 Americans lived,
and Americans had
significant financial holdings.
Wilson dispatched U.S.
troops to Veracruz in April.
They were still there
when papers reported the
assassination of Franz Ferdinand
and his wife, Sophie,
on June 28th.
Similar political assassinations
had happened in Europe before
without major international
consequences.
Few Americans, or
Europeans, for that matter,
suspected these murders
would be the small spark
that would ignite full
scale European war.
When the war came,
it immediately affected
the United States.
Stock markets closed and
remained closed for months.
U.S. trade with Europe
came to a temporary,
but tremendously costly, halt.
130,000 Americans were stranded
in Europe without access
to funds or transportation home.
And one of my favorite stories
in this book is the
rescue mission mounted
by the United States
government and private partners
to bring those Americans home.
10,000 of the Americans
approximately who were stranded
over there were teachers.
And the young gentleman
at the middle
of the cartoon is the student
who's absolutely delighted
that school is going
to be delayed.
What's so bad about
this war, he's saying.
The U.S. thought, and people all
around the world thought
everything was bad with the war.
The United States instantly
declared its neutrality.
And President Wilson would
soon embark on a quest
to guide the warring nations
to the conference table
to find a negotiated
settlement for the war.
In October, 1914, a dent in
perfect U.S. neutrality occurs.
When the Wilson administration
allows private U.S. banks
to provide substantial loans
to belligerent countries
in the event most of the money
wound up going to the allies,
but some did go to
Germany in the beginning.
Those monies would flow back
into the American conference
in the form of orders
for war material.
And those orders would
help end the recession
and put the entire
country in the black.
The book traces the
beginning and progress
of an absolutely unprecedented
outpouring of American aid
to war victims, initially on
both sides of the conflict.
And it touches on the
experiences of some
of the American men who
flouted U.S. neutrality
to join belligerent forces.
Almost all of them, although
I have found at least two
who didn't, but almost
all of them serving
in the allied armed
forces, for the conflict,
at least for Americans,
was beginning to shape
up as a contest between
militarism, autocracy,
evil and democracy,
enlightened democracy.
By the end of 1914, expectations
for a short war were dashed.
There are always, by
the way, expectations
that a war will be short.
And they're almost
never fulfilled.
The land war became an
industrial age nightmare
that introduced a host of new
and supposedly improved weapons.
It was the maritime aspect
of the conflict, however,
that most immediately
concerned Americans.
The allied surface navy blockade
of the central powers, which,
as it expanded, violated
the accepted rules
for naval blockading, was
a near constant irritant,
but an irritant generally offset
by the incoming allied
war orders.
The U-boat counter blockade
on which the Germans embarked
in February, 1915, and for
which there were no
governing rules of war.
Put American lives and
property in great peril.
The first major crisis came
when 123 Americans were among
the 1,198 people who died
when a U-boat sank the
British liner Lusitania
without warning in May, 1915.
From then until April, 1917,
President Wilson still
determined to bring both sides
to the negotiating table and
keep America out of the war.
He walked a challenging
diplomatic tightrope.
It's so well illustrated here.
While facing increased
political pleasures at home.
The American Peace Movement
remained very strong.
The preparedness movement,
primarily concerned
with national defense rather
than intervention, was growing.
This is one of my favorite
slides because of the caricature
of Kaiser Bill at the center.
It's by a French artist
that I know only as Weal,
and it's from the Willard
Straight Collection
in the Princeton
Photographs Division.
From first Germany, and
soon thereafter, Britain,
produced huge amounts of
propaganda during the war,
much of it aimed at
the United States.
By late 1915, American papers
began publishing verified
details of German
and Austro-Hungarian
espionage in the United States.
All sorts of espionage from
the relatively peaceful
to placing bombs on ships
bound for the allies.
Reports also confirmed that
German agents were seeking
to increase the turmoil
in Mexico,
to distract American
attention and resources,
and lessen the possibility
that the United States
would join the allies.
To decrease Mexican turmoil,
the Wilson Administration
in October, 1915, turned away
from supporting Pancho Villa,
who at first had seemed
the strongest candidate
to bring peace, relative
peace to Mexico,
and recognized the government
of the new [inaudible].
This, of course,
infuriated Villa.
And I should mention that George
Viereck, who is pictured here,
was a German-American editor
who established a newspaper
called The Fatherland
as soon as the war began.
And it turned out that
The Fatherland was totally
subsidized by the
German government.
David Lloyd George at the upper
left-hand corner was a cabinet
officer at this time.
And it was at his instigation
that the British government
establish what was known
as Wellington House, which was
their propaganda department,
which the United States later,
committee on public information,
would echo in many ways.
And Wellington House had a
very special department aimed
directly at influencing
American opinion.
In 1916, in January,
the American Review
of Reviews burst forth
with the following.
ROA for Europe is meaning
devastation and death.
For America, a bumper
crop of new millionaires
and a hectic hastening
of prosperity revival.
This was not an exaggeration.
And 1916 would be another
financially profitable year.
But pressures from beyond
U.S. borders were increasing.
The U-boat dangers, which waned
and waxed, and waned again
in March, when, for the second
time, the Germans pledged
that their submarines
would abide by the rules
of surface warfare, they would
not sink any merchant vessels
without prior warning,
or without seeing
passengers and crew to safety.
This was restricted
submarine warfare.
That same month, Pancho Villa
and his [inaudible] raided
Columbus, New Mexico,
murdering 17 Americans,
and infuriating their
entire country.
General John J. Pershing
led several thousand troops
into Mexico just
a week or so later
on a month's long
punitive expedition
that did not find Villa,
but did increase tensions
with the Carranza government,
and did demonstrate how
ill-prepared the United States
Army was for participation
in any major conflict.
Britain also incurred American
anger when despite U.S. pleas
for mercy, it executed the
leaders of the east arising
in Ireland in April, 1916.
And again, when the British
government issued a black list
of more than 80 American firms
and individuals suspected
of selling materials
to the central powers.
In Europe, the horrors
of war seemed
to be growing exponentially
with the Battles of Verdun
and the Somme, two long bloody
destructive slugfests occurring
in this year.
Americans served in the allied
ranks during both battles.
Poet Alan Seeger was killed
during the Battle of the Somme.
And Americans were also in
the skies above these battles.
1916, so the official debut
of a discrete American
flying unit serving
in the French forces,
the soon-to-be celebrated
Lafayette Escadrille.
At home, preparedness
forces were gaining,
now with the assistance
of President Wilson,
who said in one speech, all the
rest of the world is on fire,
but our own house
is not fireproof.
The Naval Appropriations
Act of 1916 called
for a massive expansion
of the U.S. Navy by 1925.
The National Defense Act
of the same year made some
small improvements in the Army,
increasing it to the
tremendous number of 175,000,
and made some improvements
in the National Guard,
including allowing the
president, for the first time,
to deploy National Guard troops
overseas in case of emergency.
On May 27th, Wilson also
announced a major shift
in U.S. foreign policy,
declaring the U.S.
a full partner
in international affairs.
We are participants whether
we would or not in the life
of the world, he said.
What affects mankind is
inevitably our affair.
While all of this was
happening, the American Union
against militarism was touring
American cities, making speeches
against what they saw
as the American march toward
European style militarism,
and eventual disaster.
AUAM speakers were accompanied
by a giant paper mache
dinosaur named Jingo, which was,
and I quote, all armor
plate, no brains.
1916 was also a presidential
election year.
Wilson versus former
Supreme Court Justice Charles
Evans Hughes.
And it became a very close race.
Teddy Roosevelt, who had aspired
to the nomination,
did not get it.
And he support ed Hughes,
whom he referred to privately,
I trust, at the time,
as the bearded iceberg.
It was a close race,
and not just
because Wilson still refused
to endorse a constitutional
amendment
for women's suffrage,
which he did.
Once reelected, Wilson
turned again to diplomacy,
first asking belligerent
leaders to state their war aims,
and defending both sides.
When he mentioned in his note
that from what both sides had
been saying through the war,
it seemed their war aims
were exactly the same.
And later, in January, in his
speech that came to be known
as The Peace Without Victory
Speech, in that aeration,
he asked whether this war was
quote a struggle for a just
and secure peace, or only for
a new balance of power unquote.
And he predicted very
accurately, as it turns out,
that if one side gained
victory over the other,
that would mean quote peace
forced upon the loser,
and it would leave a sting, a
resentment, a bitter memory upon
which terms of peace would
rest, not permanently,
but as only as upon quicksand.
Neither side was in
the mood for peace
without victory at this time.
And Germany had already
decided to return,
and returned forcefully to
unrestricted submarine warfare.
All belligerent and neutral
ships encountered in wide swabs
of the Atlantic Ocean
and Mediterranean Sea would
be sunk without warning.
On January 31st, Ambassador Von
Bernstorff informed Secretary
of State Robert Lansing
that this unrestricted warfare
would begin the next morning.
As insurance to protect
themselves
against the possibility
that this would bring the
United States into the war,
the new foreign minister of
Germany, Arthur Zimmerman,
sent a coded telegram to Mexico,
the soon-to-be infamous
Zimmerman telegram,
which promised Mexico a
rewarding alliance should it
join the war against the United
States should the United States
declare war.
The German announcement
did move the U.S.
to sever diplomatic
relations on February 3rd.
But it did not immediately
push the nation into war.
Many Americans were still
devoted to the cause of peace,
although opinion was
definitely turning.
America and the Great War
examines the last few weeks
of events and debates
in Congress
and among civilian
organizations,
some of which will divide
over the question of war.
It also reports on the
celebrations in March
when Tsar Nicholas of Russia,
the only autocrat
leading an allied nation,
and the only non-American on
this slide, was deposed in favor
of a liberal government that
pledged to stay in the war.
And the book traces
the tricky U.S. Russian
relations thereafter.
Jeannette Rankin, the first
woman elected to Congress,
and a dedicated pacifist, is
among 56 members of Congress
who voted against a
declaration of war.
She was also the only
member of Congress who voted
against the war declaration
in World War II.
Some of the organizations
that were divided
over the war question
included the socialists headed
by Eugene Debs who remained
a staunch anti-war person,
while other socialists
decided to further their cause
by supporting the war, and
the woman's suffrage movement,
the mainstream, the
more mainstream suffrage
organizations also decided
that war support would
benefit their cause,
and they were correct
about that.
But more radical
people, like Alice Paul,
continued to aim directly and
immediately at women's suffrage.
Alice palm and Eugene V.
Debs were jailed during the
American War.
W.E.B. Du Bois was a leading
African-American voice
for war support, believing
that war support, in this war,
as had not happened when
blacks fought in the Civil War
and in the frontier
and in the War of 1898,
but in this great war,
war support might
help support the cause
of African-American equality.
There were differences
of opinion.
The book has a quote from A.
Phillip Randolph, who said,
rather than winning the
world for democracy,
making the world safe for
democracy, wouldn't it be better
to make Georgia safe
for the Negro?
The book contemplates the
many major questions raised
by the declaration of war.
And whoops.
Too far. Would it be necessary
to send an army overseas?
And that was not
apparent immediately.
Many people in government
figured that naval support
and financial support
and building an army just
to defend the United
States would be enough.
This turned out quickly
not to be the case.
How large an army would
be needed, whether
or not we went overseas
or stayed home?
How would it be raised?
How would the war
effort be funded?
What roles should women play?
How would U.S. forces
coordinate with the larger
and more experienced and more
numerous allied Armed Forces?
It discusses the heated civilian
debate over conscription,
and the determination to build
and maintain a distinct
American army rather
than place U.S. recruits
within allied ranks.
Now we get to questions
of civil liberties,
and I will take this moment
to say that there is going
to be a symposium on that
question this afternoon at 2:00
in the Montpelier Room.
The book considers the
pressing question regarding
civil liberties.
How much freedom of
expression and freedom
of information can
be allowed even
in a proud democracy
during a time of crisis?
And this is a question
that democracies face
over and over again.
Figures in this debate include
George Creel, named in April
to head the newly formed
committee on public information;
Postmaster General
Albert Burleson,
to whom the Espionage Act passed
in June, 1917, gave wide powers
to refuse to mail
suspect material
without definite criteria for
what made materials suspect.
And peace activist and Wellesley
College professor, Emily Balch,
who spoke against a broadly
worded provision of the act
that restricted freedom
of speech.
I should add that we've put
the vigilantes' placard there.
The vigilantes were not
actually vigilantes.
They were an organization
of writers and artists
that devoted their
talents to war support.
But at this time, there was
a great deal of vigilance,
vigilante societies,
that was often supported
by the United States government.
And the book delves into
that quite deeply as well.
America and the Great
War also looks
at the mobilization
expectations and actualities.
Overall, the American war effort
was an astonishing success.
An army of 128,000 grew to one
of approximately 4 million,
2 million of whom
were sent overseas.
But there were epic problems
for this nation inexperienced
in doing anything
like this so quickly.
And the problems existed in
war department organization,
in manufacturing and
distribution of supplies
for the AEF, in transportation,
in regulating resources.
There were congressional
investigations.
Senator George Chamberlain,
a member of the president's
own political party,
became one of the severest
critics of war effort failures.
We are still unprepared
without a definite war program,
and still without trained men,
he roared in a public
speech in December, 1917.
He raised presidential hackles
by suggesting the American
war effort be directed
by a war cabinet of three
distinguished civilians
of private ability.
This did not happen.
And gradually, the
problems did not disappear.
They were reduced
to manageable size.
In November, 1917, the second
Russian revolution brought the
Bolsheviks to power.
And the Bolsheviks declared an
armistice that allowed Germany
to transfer combat divisions
to the western fronts.
More were transferred after
the Bolsheviks signed the
Brest-Litovsk Peace
Treaty in March, 1918.
By the third week in March,
as U.S. forces still requiring
training or slowly arriving,
but were not present
in sufficient numbers
to tip the scale, German forces
outnumbered allied troops
on the western front
by about two to one.
On March 21st, General
Erich Ludendorff,
not a very likeable
person, by the way,
launched a massive
five stage offensive.
And the first big blow
sent allied troops
with some ill-prepared
Americans in training mixed in,
reeling backwards
dozens of miles.
In the U.S., this frightening
news sparked measures
to get Doughboys to Europe
at a much faster pace,
many with very little training.
It also sparked an
upsurge in vigilantism,
and questionable actions by
combinations of local officials
and so-called agents
of vigilant societies.
March saw the first
so-called slacker raids,
general the attention of any man
who wasn't carrying his draft
registration card to be held
without recourse until
it was determined
that he wasn't a draft dodger.
It's probable that the bad news
from the western front also
helped pass the Sedition Act
in May.
Legislation so out of tune with
American traditions of freedom
of expression that it was
repealed shortly after the war.
America and the Great War tells
of stateside military training,
an the further training
Doughboys needed once they got
to France.
It addresses the very different
treatment accorded the nation's
white and black soldiers,
including the two black
combat divisions, the 92nd,
which served unhappily
under U.S. command,
and the under strength
93rd division, which fought
with distinction
under French command.
It tells of significant
American battle action,
including Seicheprey, Cantigny,
Belleau Wood, Chateau-Thierry,
the French-led the
Marne Offensive,
and the two major U.S.-led
offensives, Saint-Mihiel
in September, 1918, and the
four-stage Meuse-Argonne
Offensive, that lasted from late
September to the end of the war.
It provides glimpses of the
experiences of individuals,
some of whom, like future World
War II Army Chief of Staff
and post-war Secretary,
post-World War II Secretary
of State, George
Marshall, are familiar.
Others are relatively unknown.
General Pershing called the much
decorated Sam Woodfill the most
outstanding U.S.
soldier of the war.
John Lang, whose papers are in
the Veterans History Project,
was one of 300 men of the sixth,
U.S. sixth engineers
completely untrained in combat,
who were caught in the
first phase, the first wave
of the March, 1918 German
Offensive, and mainly joined
with British units to
fight their way out.
Born in Scotland, Lang became
an American citizen shortly
after the war.
The book also follows 4,000
U.S. troops to Archangel
in the frozen north of Russia.
And 9,000 Russian,
9,000 U.S. troops
to Vladivostok in Siberia.
And it follows the newly formed
U.S. third army into Germany
after the November
11th armistice
to begin occupation duties.
The book follows the continuing
and amazing war support effort
at home and events that
affected that effort,
including the sudden appearance
of U-boats just off the coast
of the east coast that briefly
placed the Navy Department
under siege from
concerned citizens.
In late August, the Spanish flu
pandemic hit the United States
in force, taking an estimated
500,000 American lives before
it abated.
The book's epilogue describes
the multiple questions
and problems resulting
from bringing
to a rapid halt a war effort
that was just beginning
to hit its peak in efficiency
and in emotional fervor.
It goes abroad with
Woodrow Wilson,
the first sitting president
to travel to Europe,
and touches on the vast hopes
and bitter disappointments
that resulted from that journey.
It describes post-war
violence in the United States,
as labor lost many
of its wartime gains
in the bloody strike
torn year of 1919.
And African-American
hopes that their support
for the war would advance the
cause of equality were dashed
in a period of racial violence.
Bolshevism replaced Prussianism
as a prime target of vigilantism
in the country, as
the country went
through its first red scare,
the second would happen
after the second world war.
On a more positive note,
Congress finally did
pass the 19th amendment
to the Constitution
after it had languished
for many months in the Senate.
Its ratification on August 18th,
1920, meant that after decades
of struggle, American women
had the constitutional right
to vote.
Women were among the voters who
heeded Warren Harding's call
for a return to normalcy
that gained him the
White House in 1920.
By then, the United States,
facing no discernible
military threat,
had reduced its army
to 137,000 men.
In other vastly significant
ways, however,
there could be no turning back.
The United States had emerged
from the war the
world's leading economic
and a premier political power,
with demonstrated potential
for projecting military
might abroad.
It had failed to join
the League of Nations,
but it was soon working
unofficially
with league committees to
assure the continuing peace
and stability that was so
vital to U.S. interests.
In 1921, the United States
organized a successful five
nation naval disarmament
conference.
Shortly thereafter, recognizing
the country's new position
in the world and the truth
of Wilson's 1916 statement
that we are participants
whether we would or not
in the life of the world.
A number of prominent
Americans formed the council
on foreign relations
to be better prepared,
as the council history notes,
for significant responsibilities
and decisionmakings
in world affairs.
As venerable American
statesman Elihu Root,
one of the council's
founders, stated in 1922,
I suppose that the people of the
United States have learned more
about international relations
within the past eight years
than they have learned in
the preceding 80 years.
They are, however, only at
the beginning of the task.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
I think we may have some time
for questions if anyone has any,
preferably ones that
I can answer.
Yes?
>> What surprised you most as
you were doing your research?
>> Oh my. So many
things surprised me.
Individual people surprised me.
I discovered many
interesting characters.
But I think the depth of
American, of the effect
of the war on America right from
the very beginning surprised me.
The first world war, as people
who knew me have heard me say ad
infinitum has been an interest
of mine since I was
a little girl.
But it was mostly interest
in what I consider the
appallingly futile war effort
that killed so many
people uselessly.
I did not really delve into the
political or social history,
and certainly not the way it
affected the United States.
So this was sort of a gradual
and continuing surprise
as to how deeply it
reached into our society.
Sir?
>> Could you talk about how
your view of Woodrow Wilson?
>> Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Now there's a question.
>> If you can answer it.
>> Well, how much
time do you have?
I find Woodrow Wilson to be
a very frustrating individual
to understand.
He is a person of deep
and abiding ideals
and religious faith.
He is a product of
his time and place.
He was a Virginian who
remembered the Civil War
when he was a little boy.
He was-- his ideals and his
idealistic speech are very
moving, but then he also
could be a very small man.
And I think in some ways,
his unwillingness to listen
to criticism is what helped
do American participation
in the League of Nations.
Whether that would have
helped the league survive,
I don't know, but I
believe it would have.
So I feel more closely
acquainted with Woodrow Wilson,
or slightly more closely
acquainted, but with each step
of closer acquaintance, I feel
more frustrated by the man.
Sir?
>> One of the more surprising
things I learned was the amount
of industry in the treaty that
was going on between the U.S.
and Baltimore, and
I was wondering
if you could talk
a little bit more
about what specific
commodities were being shipped
over to the belligerents,
and then the sort
of delicate response
of U.S. government
when the allies expressed
their frustration.
>> Well, even during a
period of neutrality,
because of the blockage,
almost much of the American
supply line was heading directly
to allied nations.
Things that were regarded as
contraband could be confiscated
under the rules of blockaded
by the allied navies.
The British Navy basically
controlled the Atlantic.
There was an episode in
the book, the Germans,
and in real life, incidentally,
where the Germans developed
commerce submarines.
They were huge submarines
that could be packed
with a lot of supplies.
And only one of them
made it to America.
Came over here twice.
It was the Deutschland.
And it was a very happy occasion
because it brought over,
from both the Germans and the
Americans, because it brought
over [inaudible] that we
had been getting exclusively
from Germany.
And our industries
were suffering.
And it took back feeling
under the blockade,
it took back contraband
materials.
When some supplies did go to
Germany and Austria-Hungry,
I think most of those were
considered relief supplies.
I don't know if that sort
of answers your question.
Sir?
>> There seems to be a lot
of vague considerations
of why we went to war.
[ Inaudible ]
Some people say that the most
definite was the financial
complications of
the British coming
to natural institutions
in the United States.
Do you have an opinion on that?
>> Yeah, that's a toughy.
A lot of the people
who still objected
to the United States' entry
into the war, several of them
like Robert La Follette, Eugene
Debs, they objected to our entry
because they felt it was
for financial reasons,
to increase our prosperity.
I think it was a
mixture of reasons.
I think there was
an emotional factor.
I think many Americans,
and Americans
at that time were remarkably,
many of them, idealistic.
Many Americans really
did see the war,
especially once Russia
lost the Tsar,
as a fight of good against evil.
A lot of this stemmed
from allied propaganda,
some of it accurate and some of
it not, about German atrocities.
But a lot of it stemmed
from German espionage
in the United States
and the U-boat wars.
I think also that Woodrow
Wilson led the country into war,
in part because he felt
that that was the only way
that America and he, as the
head of the United States,
could influence a
post-war peace.
As a matter of fact, in February
of 1917, he got a letter
from David Lloyd George with a
tremendously flattering letter
that said we're not urging
the United States to go to war
for your military assistance or
for your financial assistance,
though those things are
important, but to earn you,
Woodrow Wilson, a seat at
the table as the leader
of the disinterested country,
a country that has no interest
in securing territory,
a country not so warped
by these years of war.
It's a letter calculated
to turn anyone's head.
Whether it turned his head,
I think that was the
sort of thinking he had.
He was very much an idealist,
an infuriating idealist,
but an idealist.
Yes?
>> I loved all-- in the exhibit,
I loved all of the personal
stories from individuals.
>> Yes.
>> And some of them say
like veteran project.
>> Veterans History Project.
>> Now, how do you
guys get those?
Because I thought the Library
of Congress was just, you know,
wasn't really for private
citizens to have stuff in there.
>> Private citizens have
a lot of stuff in here.
Yes, and if you go
to the Veterans History
Project website,
there's a whole instruction
to tell you how to go
about donating materials, and
how to interview veterans.
But the library accepts
donations all the time.
I am not a curator, so I cannot
speak to the rules of donations,
but if you turn around and talk
to the two women behind you,
they could probably
help you out.
I can take one more question.
Yes?
>> Can you tell us a little
more about the fighting
in eastern Europe and
the impact of the war
on immigrant relations
in the United States?
>> That is a huge question.
I did concentrate on
the war in the west,
although I did follow our
relations with Russia,
from right when we
entered the war.
The war on the east was
particularly difficult
and savage.
It was particularly hard
on the Russian nation,
which lost territory.
The war on the east helped
tear the Austria-Hungarian
Empire apart.
Many, and as to the
impact on immigrants
in the United States,
that varied so much.
Some recent immigrants
returned when they could
to their home countries,
whichever they may
have happened to be.
Many immigrants, many
recent immigrants,
many first generation
Americans fought
on the allied side
in the American army.
There were, I can't remember
the percentage right now,
of immigrant Americans
that comprised the AEF.
Many of them could
not speak English,
and there's a little
anecdote in the book
about Polish-American officer
visiting a training camp,
and where there were
a lot of Polish,
recent Polish immigrants.
And they had not gotten any
of the training down pat,
because none of their officers,
none of their training
officers could speak any Polish,
and they didn't understand
any English.
And episodes like that
led to the development
of training units with
bilingual officers
to train American soldiers, AEF
soldiers, both in the language,
and also in the arts of war.
That's a partial answer,
but it's a big question.
Okay, I think if that's-- if
there are no more questions,
thank you again very
much for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.